[Musique]
Jean-Marc janovicii bonjour bonjour vous
êtes associé de Carbon 4 vous êtes
président de the shift project et vous
avez publié fin 2015 dormez tranquille
jusqu'en 200 et autrre malentendu sur le
climat et l'énergie aux éditions odal
Jacob alors le postulat de base de ce
livre c'est que toute situation
économique et par extension sociale et
politique dépend avant tout de la
quantité d'énergie consommée dans une
économie alors je vais lire un passage
pour commencer un passage qui fait
réfléchir tous ceux qui font des
prévisions économiques et exerfi on est
concerné depuis les années 80 le PIB par
personne en moyenne mondiale varie très
exactement avec une ou de années de
décalage comme la production mondiale de
pétrole en volume indépendamment des
prix est-ce que cela veut dire que
puisque la production baisse en ce
moment il faut s'attendre à une
récession très bientôt la réponse est
oui tu reste on envoie les prémisses en
ce moment euh tout tout le monde est en
train de se gratter la tête sur le
ralentissement des émergents la
croissance qui repart pas tant que ça
dans les pays de l'OCDE en fait quand on
regarde la situation économique dans les
pays de l'OCDE la croissance est
repartie sur la base de l'augmentation
patrimoniale d'une toute petite partie
de la population les salaires sont pas
repartis le taux d'emploi est pas revenu
à ce qu'il était en 2007 la production
industrielle baisse un peu partout et
tout ça devient très logique si on fait
intervenir l'énergie parce que l'énergie
c'est la nourriture des machines et en
fait la civilisation industrielle ça
n'est rien d'autre que d'avoir transféré
la transformation du monde des hommes
aux machines à l'époque du Moyen-Âge
c'était nos bras et nos jambes qui
transformaient le monde pas vite pas de
manière massive pas très rapidement donc
le PIB était proportionnel à la
population plus vous aviez de bras et de
jambes et plus vous transformiez
l'environnement et quand on est passé
aux machines ce qui transforme
l'environnement aujourd'hui c'est les
machines les machines mangent de
l'énergie et les machines sont quelques
centaines de fois plus puissantes que
les hommes donc c'est vraiment ça qui
fait la différence et donc s'il y a
moins d'énergie pour les machines et en
particulier moins de pétrole pour
alimenter les transports vous avez moins
de PIB ça marche extrêmement bien alors
j'ai relevé un autre passage vous
n'allez pas vous faire que des amis
parmi les écologistes en annonçant des
émissions croissantes sans limite en cas
d' inaction contre le réchauffement
climatique les partisans de l'action
accrédite paradoxalement une idée très
sympathique ne rien faire signifierait
une économie encore en croissance sur 85
ans quoi que puisse faire le climat oui
c'est c'est enfin c'est une manière dont
les gens comprennent implicitement
l'affirmation qui est si on ne fait rien
les émissions augmentent jusqu'en 2100
parce que qu'est-ce que c'est que des
émissions qui augmentent dans l'esprit
de tout le monde c'est une consommation
d'énergie qui augmente qu'est-ce que
c'est qu'une consommation d'énergie qui
augmente dans l'esprit de tout le monde
c'est un paym qui augmente donc en gros
quand on dit si on ne fait rien les
émissions augmentent jusqu'en 200 on est
en train de dire si on ne fait rien
l'économie est en croissance jusqu'en
200 alors du coup la majeure partie des
gens vont dire pourquoi voulez-vous
qu'on fasse quelque chose puisque si on
ne fait rien tout va bien entre
guillemets jusqu'en 2100 évidemment
c'est une vue de l'esprit je essaie
d'expliquer dans ce livre dont le titre
est évidemment à prendre au second degré
euh c'est que les désordres liés à
l'inaction il commence déjà à se faire
sentir dès à présent à la fois sur le
plan économique et sur le plan
environnemental et que si on ne fait
rien entre guillemets c'est pas des
émissions croissantes jusqu'en 200 c'est
des émissions qui vont arrêter de
croître bien avant 200 parce que le fait
de ne rien avoir fait entre pas enfin
entre guillemets euh va rendre le monde
suffisamment hostile pour que l'économie
ne puisse plus être en croissance mais
au contraire va devenir structurellement
en récession mais alors comment est-ce
qu'on fait pour décorréler croissance et
Pétro est-ce que on peut concilier les
objectifs de sobriété énergétique et
croissance formellement oui
factuellement très difficilement parce
que quand on regarde ce que les gens
comprennent comme étant la croissance de
l'économie ils comprennent ça comme
étant la croissance des mètres carrés
disponibles par personne la croissance
du nombre de voitures disponibles par
personne la croissance du nombre de
voyages en train disponibl par personne
du nombre d'ignion disponibles par
personne et cetera et tout ça se traduit
tant que la comptabilité nationale était
faite pour ça par une augmentation du
PIB par personne mais ça se traduit
aussi par une augmentation de la
production industrielle c'estàd plus de
table plus de chaisees plus de mètres
carrés plus de lunettes tout ça c'est
l'augmentation de la production
industrielle or transformer de plus en
plus de matière pour faire des tables
des chaises et des lunettes en utilisant
de moins en moins d'énergie à un moment
vous butez sur une impossibilité
physique donc le fait que le fait enfin
l'idée qu'on va arriver à résoudre les
grands problèmes d'environnement dans le
monde à 9 milliards d'individus avec un
PIB par personne en augmentation
personnellement j'y crois pas et comment
expliquer que aujourd'hui les euh les
énergies vert entre guillemets ou encore
les énergies non conventionnelles ne
permettent pas encore de prendre le
relais sur les cro sur les énergies
fossiles une des choses que j'explique
dans ce livre aussi c'est que
historiquement nous sommes passés des
énergies vertes aux énergies pas vertes
donc quand on regarde la civilisation
humaine elle s'est d'abord développée
avec le soleil le vent le bois et cetera
et si on est passé à ces affreuses
choses que sont le pétrole le charbon et
l'horreur absolue pour les Français qui
l'uranium c'est bien parce que ces
énergiesl avaient des avantages sur les
énergies renouvelables euh alors elles
n'ont elles ont un gros inconvénient
elles sont pas renouvelables un deuxième
gros inconvénient pour les énergies
carbonées c'est qu'elles changent le
climat sinon pour le reste elles sont
beaucoup mieux que les énergie
renouvelable elles sont beaucoup plus
faciles à extraire de l'environnement
donc elles coûtent beaucoup moins cher
et elles offrent la possibilité d'une
palette d'usage beaucoup plus vaste
quand on pense énergie renouvelable en
France on pense essentiellement solaire
et éolien il faut savoir que c'est
l'arbre qui cache la forêt euh sur les
15 dernières années dans le monde
l'énergie qui a le plus augmenté et de
très loin c'est le charbon et et il a
augmenté 30 fois plus que le solaire
donc ce qui se passe en ce moment dans
le monde c'est pas du tout l' sort des
énergies renouvelables c'est les sort du
charbon voilà ben encore des petites
choses à méditer merci beaucoup
Jean-Marc Jancovici pour ceux qui
veulent aller plus loin dormez
tranquille jusqu'en 200 et autres
malentendu sur le climat et l'énergie
aux éditions audil Jacob merci beaucoup
[Musique]
merci